realmente no podemos saber en qué
momento vamos a necesitar hacer la
planeación de una fiesta de algún rey
así que no duele en nada esforzarnos un
poco en práctica este tipo de sistemas
de ocupaciones que tengo aquí así que en
este caso quiero resolver para x y
usando el método de eliminación o el de
suma y resta estas dos ecuaciones que
tengo aquí menos 2 x menos 6 esto es
igual a menos 64 y por otra parte 13 x 5
y esto es igual a menos 44 y bueno si te
das cuenta no las puedo trabajar aquí no
puedo yo a rallar esta parte de aquí así
que mejor vamos a sacar nuestro pizarrón
electrónico nuestra libreta de notas y
ya está aquí tengo ya el mismo problema
si te das cuenta son las mismas
ecuaciones menos 12 x 6 james esto es
igual a menos 64 y 3 x menos 5 y esto es
igual a menos 44 ahora si yo quiero
resolver este sistema utilizando un
método de eliminación date cuenta que si
yo sumo las dos ecuaciones no sé
el any x si yo sumo 3x menos 2x no se
cancela x y si yo sumo menos 6 más menos
5 y tampoco se cancela bien entonces en
este caso seguramente te vas a preguntar
y ahora qué hacemos y bueno la respuesta
es muy simple pero es muy importante lo
que hay que hacer es buscar la forma de
eliminar alguna de estas variables
multiplicando las dos ecuaciones o
solamente una de ellas de tal manera que
después de que multipliquemos estas
ecuaciones al sumarlas se puedan
cancelar y bueno lo que se me ocurre
aquí de una manera muy rápida es que
podemos cancelar a la equis solamente
porque tenemos una positiva una positiva
y una negativa en este caso creo que
sería bueno eliminar el x solamente por
esa condición pero bueno también
podríamos trabajar con la y ahora si te
das cuenta que tengo menos 2x y acá
abajo tengo 13 x positivo por lo tanto
qué te parece si multiplicó a la
ecuación de arriba a toda la ecuación de
arriba la voy a multiplicar por 3 ok ya
toda la ecuación de abajo
toda la ecuación debajo la voy a
multiplicar por 2 de tal manera que
cuando yo multiplique 3 por menos 2 me
dé menos seis y dos por tres de seis y
ahora sí pueda cancelar la equis
entonces vamos a ver de la primera que
obtengo y de la segunda que obtengo de
la primera voy a obtener tres por menos
2x esto me va a quedar menos 6x ok 3 x
menos 6 y estos menos 18 y de lujo ok y
esto es igual a 3 x menos 64 bueno mi
resultado es negativo pero tú sabes
cuánto estrés pues de 4
vamos a hacerlo aquí 64 por 3 y dice 3
por 42 si llevamos 13 por 6 18 y 119 3
por 4 12 ok
192 esto es igual a menos 192 ok ahora
hagamos lo mismo con la ecuación de
abajo lo voy a multiplicar todo por 2 y
me queda seis veces x
3x por 2 6 veces x menos 5 por 2 bueno
estos menos 10 bien ok y después para
finalizar me queda menos 44 por 2 esos
menos 88 y ahora qué te parece si
sumamos estas dos ecuaciones voy a sumar
esta parte de estas dos ecuaciones de mi
lado izquierdo y esta parte de mi lado
derecho de estas dos ecuaciones y
recuerda que puedo hacer eso porque yo
sé que menos 6 x menos 10 es lo mismo
que menos 88 es decir que realmente lo
que estoy haciendo es sumar menos 88 de
ambos lados de esta ecuación ahora
hagámoslo y si lo hacemos ya estamos en
el momento en el que se puede cancelar
una de las variables en este momento se
puede cancelar la equis porque aquí
tengo menos 6x y aquí tengo 6x y logré
hacer esto multiplicando por tres la
primera actuación por este número que
tengo aquí y la segunda ecuación la
multiplicada por dos por este número que
tengo aquí y ahora sí que me queda bueno
menos 18 james menos 10 bueno esos menos
28 y menos
28 bien esto es igual a menos 192 menos
88 bueno aquí le sumó 8 me quedan 200
280 ok menos 280 y de aquí de una manera
muy fácil yo puedo despejar ayer si yo
he vivido todo entre menos 28 todo entre
menos 28
entonces me va a quedar que estos dos se
van ok y james es igual a menos entre
menos me dan más ok
28 entre 28 es 10 y voy a quitar este
más porque recuerda que nosotros no
ponemos el signo eso significa que este
10 tiene el signo positivo que es igual
a 10 ok
una vez que yo conseguí el valor de
james que te parece si utilizar alguna
de estas dos ecuaciones de espejo a x y
se me ocurre utilizar la de abajo porque
x es positiva
entonces me va a quedar 3 veces x menos
5 veces jmv pero que vale menos 10
entonces voy a multiplicar por 10 por 10
positivo que vale 10 positivo perdón
esto es igual esto es igual a menos 40
4 - 44 o dicho otra manera 3 veces x
menos 50 esto es igual a 44 negativo
pues pero es menos 44 menos 44 ok o
dicho de otra manera si somos 50 voy a
sumar 50 de ambos lados de la ecuación
aquí se encuentra y x 50
entonces me va a quedar que de este lado
estos dos se van y me queda que 3x es
igual a 50 menos 44 lo cual es 6 o dicho
otra manera x es igual a 2 ok si
dividido de ambos lados entre 3 y
entonces ya llegué al 9 expuesta x
igualados e igual a 10 hacen que el
sistema de ecuaciones se cumplan bueno o
al menos eso creemos que te parece si
verificamos con estas dos ecuaciones que
me quedaría veamos y si sirven entonces
de esta ecuación de que arriban me va a
quedar menos 2x es decir menos 2 por x
pero x vale 2
ok menos 6 por james es decir menos 6
por 10 porque lle vale 10 según esto
esto debe ser igual a menos 60
y será cierto pues veamos menos 2 x 2 -
4 - 4 - 6 x 10 y 60 ok esto debe ser
igual a menos 64 y esto si se cumple
menos 4 menos 60 es menos 64 por lo
tanto si se cumple la primera ecuación
déjame ponerle aquí que si se cumple ok
ahora probemos con la segunda ecuación
tengo 3x menos 5 y esto es igual a menos
44 vamos a ver qué nos sale por aquí me
quedaría 3 por equis pero x vale 2 3 por
2 menos 5 porque pero llévale 10 ok esto
es igual a menos 44 de lujo 3 por 12 66
menos 50 esto debe de ser igual a menos
44 ok y aquí tengo 50 menos 650 menos
644 pero el que gana es negativo por lo
tanto me va a quedar que menos 44 menos
44 es igual a menos 44 que es justo lo
que yo quería
al menos 44 por lo tanto de lujo ya
tenemos la respuesta también se cumple
la segunda ecuación y por lo tanto
10 y x2 hacen que se cumpla este sistema
de ecuaciones así que vamos a escribirlo
aquí en la página x igual a 2 x igual a
2 igual a 10 ok ponemos la página por
aquí x igual a 2 y igual a 10 y veamos
si estamos bien del lujo si estamos bien
hasta la próxima